paola antonelli curator of architecture
& Design Museum of Modern Art New York i
was born in sardinia grew up in milan so
I'm Italian growing up in Milan exposed
me to all sorts of design forms from
architecture to industrial design
furniture design and fashion and I used
up all of it and being born in Sardinia
made me have one of the biggest
breakthroughs in my life that's when I
decided to move from economics to
architecture so that was basically the
beginning of my new life I was young and
I was very arrogant and I had enrolled
in the hardest possible course at the
university was this highfalutin course
of economics at the bocconi university
and I remember that two years after
having started I was really unhappy and
I remember being on a rock in the sea in
Sardinia saying what do I do and all of
a sudden I decided you know what I'm
going to go the opposite direction and
it was a really quiet but very strong
decision because architectural school in
Milan at that time was pure chaos it was
like 15,000 students no structure
whatsoever only a small fraction would
actually graduate hardly anybody heavily
nobody would become an architect you
know they would become pizza makers
chefs fashion designer so it was really
the opposite from completely structured
the bokoni to totally instructed all
possibilities open but also no knowledge
of what the future would bring there are
some people that are born with a mission
I was not aged 9 I wanted to become an
astronaut so I wrote to NASA from
Italian I told him I want to become an
astronaut and they were very kind they
responded they told me that's wonderful
so you have to stay in school you have
to study especially mathematics you have
to take very good care of your health
especially your teeth because you know
at that time the pressure and the
spaceships was not like perfectly fine
tuned so I was happy it was doing my
whole thing and then aged 11 I get my
first cavity so desperation I can't be
an astronaut anymore so I went from that
to astrophysics I was reading you know
just whatever divulge ative book
could find that I went from that to
nuclear physics in the meantime I was
drawing garments and clothes I mean
completely all over the map you know and
then writing for a newspaper as a
teenage higher and then economics so I
changed many times and but i have to say
there's always a design also in your
destiny because I just ended up in the
profession that I was meant to be in
from the beginning I just didn't know it
I just followed the waves you know I
consider myself a really good surfer
even though I've never been on a board
in my life